what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some more news about
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in Deadpool 3.
news about Deadpool and Wolverine's
relationship in the film how they're
going to act towards each other but also
a little bit of information about if
Hugh Jackman is going to stick around as
Wolverine even after Deadpool 3 is done
I did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure right
I think a lot of fans have been hoping
that Wolverine would stick around for at
least Secret Wars even if Deadpool 3
does not result in Wolverine sticking
around in the MCU there is always the
possibility that while all the
incursions happen and everything that's
going on in Avengers Secret Wars happens
he could be brought back into the MCU
and help fight in the final battle
against king or perhaps another
mysterious villain that could possibly
show up maybe even Doctor Doom but for
now we're thinking the big bad is a
variant of King the Conqueror but our
question today is Will Wolverine be
around to fight him well luckily for us
we have some information coming directly
from Hugh Jackman himself in a recent
interview so we'll dive into that today
but first big reminder we still have a
week left of our giveaway and next year
we're going to kick off some new
giveaways as well this week we're
picking a winner to win a Marvel Legends
item to enter all you got to do is
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below let us know in this
video what you think the relationship
will be like between Deadpool and
Wolverine how would you like to see it
so obviously everybody is just super
ecstatic that Wolverine is returning
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine specifically is
returning of course we're going to be
getting a new Wolverine in the future
but not before Hugh Jackman returns
which I think is really really fantastic
and a lot of fans are super excited
about but a big question that a lot of
fans have had is this going to be a one
and done for Hugh Jackman as he's simply
returning for one movie Deadpool 3 and
then he's done or could he possibly
stick around in the MCU for a little bit
longer well Hugh Jackman recently spoke
up about this while he was doing an
interview with the Empire film podcast
now just for a little bit of backstory
before Hugh Jackman after Logan and
incoming spoiler alert for Logan if you
haven't seen it yet but after Logan
after the death of Wolverine and the
death of Professor Xavier both Hugh
Jackman and Patrick Stewart said that
they were done with their characters
once and for all that was their final
goodbye and that no matter what happened
they wouldn't want to undo it however
New Opportunities have arised thanks to
the Multiverse Patrick Stewart did
return as per Professor Xavier in
Multiverse of Madness however this was a
variant to Professor Xavier so it was
not the same one from Logan they did not
undo his death so his goodbye to that
character was still somewhat the final
goodbye and the same goes for Logan
Wolverine and Hugh Jackman this will be
a different variant of Wolverine in fact
Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds have
already confirmed that they're not going
to touch the death of Logan they're not
going to undo that at all and this is
actually important because this means
that whatever variant we are getting of
Wolverine he can stick around because he
doesn't have to return to an old
timeline to die if it is the same
Wolverine from the same exact timeline
and they didn't want to change anything
ultimately he would have to return to
that timeline to eventually go on to die
however Hugh Jackman is already stated
in a recent interview this Wolverine
we're going to see is from a different
timeline therefore he does not have to
go back he can stay inside of the MCU
but will he in the Empire film podcast
interview he was asked if he was already
thinking about his return to the
character for the new movie with Ryan
Reynolds as a one and done movie or if
it was the start of a new chapter as
Wolverine and here's what he said in the
interview I imagine every movie as a one
and done that's how I see it and I'll be
honest I had a two-picture deal at the
beginning but I still assumed it was a
one and done you know back then there
were no comic book movies so I just take
it one at a time I'm lucky that way I
don't have to think beyond that but I
think it's the best way to go now the
whole two picture deal in the beginning
I think he is referring to the very
first X-Men film when he was cast as
Wolverine for the first time however
there is still the possibility that he
could be talking about a second
appearance in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I won't speculate too much
about this but I would be surprised if
he was simply one and done with this
movie and I'll explain more about why I
think that in just a bit but let's
finish this interview for first he went
on to offer some more details about the
movie speaking about the relationship
between Wolverine and Deadpool that will
happen in the movie and he said how do I
categorize it tin being really close
zero being the reality we're zero we're
opposites hate each other I'm just
talking from my perspective Logan's
frustrated by him Wants To Be A Million
Miles Away From Him or wants to punch
him in the head unfortunately he can't
be a million miles away from him in this
movie so I'm probably going to punch him
in the head a lot so there you have it
some pretty decent details about
Wolverine and Deadpool specifically
about their relationship in Deadpool 3.
now Ryan Reynolds has already spilled
some of the beans telling us that
Deadpool 3 is kind of going to be a road
trip between two best friends talking
about Wolverine and Deadpool but he also
said that it was going to be rashamon
style so to me things are becoming a
little bit more clear based off of what
Hugh Jackman said and Ryan Reynolds has
said because the movie rashmon is about
the death of a samurai and they go
through many different people's
perspectives in which they all remember
it a little bit differently they
remember what happened differently so as
we can already see here it looks like
Wolverine can't get away from Deadpool
for whatever reason possibly because
they are both running from the TVA or
perhaps something Deadpool did that
makes it to where Wolverine has to stick
with him but they're both kind of taking
a card trip together probably to other
universes and Wolverine can't stand
Deadpool however Deadpool being as
sarcastic as he is probably sees it
differently than Wolverine sees it
Deadpool's probably having the time of
his life because he's with his good old
pal Wolverine while at the same time
Wolverine kind of hates the whole entire
situation because Deadpool is well
Deadpool plus not to mention Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman have already
teased that they're going to be fighting
each other and it looks like they're
going to be fighting each other quite a
bit
and honestly since Hugh Jackman and Ryan
Reynolds are indeed best friends in real
life we know that no matter what they're
doing chemistry is going to be there
whether they love each other as
characters or hate each other as
characters it's all going to be
absolutely fantastic and that leads me
to believe that Hugh Jackman won't be
one and done if Ian did sign a two movie
contract I am assuming that the next
movie is either going to be Deadpool 4
or Secret Wars and considering how
Deadpool 3 is coming right before Secret
Wars I would assume Wolverine is coming
in secret Wars because why wouldn't he
if all of these different variants from
these other universes are coming why
wouldn't Wolverine be there as well
specifically Hugh Jackman's Wolverine it
wouldn't really make sense to wait till
Deadpool 4 because that's going to come
years after Secret Wars however even if
Hugh Jackman only signed a one movie
deal a one and done deal he says that
all of his movies are like this or
that's at least how he perceives them
which means that even if he is just
doing a one and done deal he is open to
coming back for another movie and I'm
actually going to assume he will be
coming back for another movie because I
think him and Ryan Reynolds are going to
have just a ton of fun filming Deadpool
3 together and Hugh Jackman has stated
that one thing he regrets is not being
able to be a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and interact with
these other characters that is now a
reality to him and Ryan Reynolds and
Hugh Jackman have already stated that it
wasn't Ryan Who convinced Hugh to come
back Hugh came back on his own because
he wanted to so since Hugh Jackman came
back to playing Wolverine on his own and
since he now has the opportunity to play
in that big MCU sandbox and he's doing a
movie with one of his best friends I'm
assuming he's going to have the time of
his life and he'll want to return for
another movie to play Wolverine but that
is just my thought process what do you
all think about this as well do you
think he's going to be one and done or
do you think he'll stick around in the
MCU for at least Secret Wars and maybe
even more maybe Deadpool 4. let us know
your thoughts down below and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date with all the latest
news for live updates you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof